foreign
students the vast majority will not go
on to play in any professional league if
there's one that exists for their sport
so this is an opportunity for them to
start a business based on who they are
and in Florida we just as I said we
literally just signed the bill by
Governor DeSantis uh yesterday and uh
this is now in effect for anybody who
wants to transfer to the State of
Florida and once they're here uh have
some great opportunities you cannot
induce an athlete to go to a university
based on the deals they might get they
have to already be signed up to be a
contracted player and student at for
example Florida State University once
they're there the coach or staff can now
help them get endorsements from local
restaurants car dealerships
whoever is willing to sponsor that
athlete and and of note I mean a lot of
these athletes obviously are going to be
your your Revenue generating sports like
football and basketball all but there's
a lot of great opportunities that we've
seen for female athletes non-traditional
sport male or female athletes and you
know this just kind of open opens the
door for people to be creative if you're
an athlete and you want to go into
commentating or reporting uh and and you
want to build your brand obviously the
more presence you have in social media
or in the business world as a as an
athlete and as a college student the
more that is going to catapult you into
whatever that other industry is is going
to be if it's not Sports so I think it's
important for them to learn not just the
value of money how to save how to make
sure that you cover your tax bill and
things like that but also how to
monetize who you are and you know or the
the world today is is very much Social
and digital and and people are going to
have that opportunity to you know Build
That Brand online and also with
merchandise and things like that so I
think it's really important for their
future to have this opportunity not
everyone's going to do it but the those
who do I hope they do it well here in
the state of Florida
the reality is you've got students who
will be in college and won't have a pro
league to go to or even if there is may
not get drafted may not play uh you've
got cases like at Florida State you know
Sarah Blakely with uh Spanx product you
know invented that you know shortly
after leaving school you can invent
something in school as an athlete as
part of your brand you could you could
have an endorsement deal that goes from
being the quarterback of the Florida
State Seminoles to you know it you could
parlay it in into uh you may Auto maybe
you do some Automotive advertising or
endorsements ultimately you end up in
the automotive industry or you're a
brand uh you're a brand for other other
Industries so I think that the biggest
part of what I'm proud of this bill is
the entrepreneurship piece and that's
starting to learn how to capitalize on
who you are
foreign